and and we spoke about strategy of
refund or companies and i i told you
this statement
the best strategy is the study that
everybody understands
that you are the only one that can
perform and and we do have this strategy
of
deep tech and we are the right people to
perform
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
i am so excited for this upcoming guest
dove
managing partner of grow ventures and
one of the most prominent israeli
high-tech leaders in the world
an investor inventor and entrepreneur
best known as the inventor of the usb
flash drive
founded m systems acquired by
sandisk for
1.6 billion us dollars in 2006.
today he is the managing partner of grow
ventures a leading early stage venture
capital investment firm
which places significant emphasis on
deep technology and partners with
exceptional israeli entrepreneurs
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm honored
to be in the grove offices
i get to see you often i often come with
a video camera which is weird because
very soon i'm going to start coming in
with sly decks
so so you get ready for that but in the
meantime i'm gonna pick your brain for
these 20 minutes about who you are and i
want to know both about
you know where we are right now which is
very representative to where you are i
think in life right now
with deep technology investments but but
really understand the world
the word deep technology it's been
thrown out a lot
everywhere everybody loves to say
they're dealing with deep technology but
what really is
deep technology in the core sense of it
and and why do you get so excited i want
to ask you about that and then i also
want to talk
take you back you know back to your army
days back to your high school days
20 weeks it ended you don't have time
talking about myself
uh okay okay okay i was joking with you
where are we
venture capital fund uh early stage new
technology now
what is deep technology big technology
the way i see it and of course
many people see it differently deep
technology is the hardcore the things
which are really
the the the tough things
in the high tech world which is
semiconductor
and hardware sensors and air
ai or cloud infrastructure or science we
do believe in science as well we invest
in science
and this leads into many many things
which could be in the variety of markets
but we look for the things that are how
to replicate
uh usually where there are patterns
where there are
ideas which are really out of the box
um in technology not just in marketing
and basically you know things which are
changing the world and
practically making this world a bit
better
so you know what i i've had the unique
pleasure of having almost 400 people on
the show and
i could swear that practically everybody
says they're they're making the world a
better place and they're changing the
world
i really want to understand here because
the approach that you're taking with
growth the deep technology approach and
we just had a fascinating almost
hour-long conversations
and you started telling me about two or
three companies that you invested in and
i
almost couldn't buy into the fact that
you're running the company because
you're so excited about what they're
doing
true what is what is making an impact
mean to you when it comes to deep
technology how does the technology
translate
to making a strong impact on the world
well okay we do have the answer
but first of all if you came to the
offices you could see that
the entrance to the office there is a
sign saying
large letters people first we do believe
in people
anything which we do relate to people
they they found
our the entrepreneurs who are coming to
us the
people we are investing in how do what
is the most important criteria
where we use the help is how do we treat
our lps for people first
and the second principle is creating
value
we are eager to create value we are
determined to invest where value
but the company really brings true value
to the world
where we can add value to the company
where we can add value to our investors
of course
we were talking about why why you're
deciding that why
your thesis is that new technology
companies are the right way to make it
strong
so so generally so we we're eager to
bring value
now deep tech in what we are doing any
company we are investing in
is a company that makes a difference
this company
makes an impact it's a company that many
many cases
saves the life of people or change life
of people
that's very very crucial to us now
we don't invest in cyber we don't invest
in fintech we don't
invest in a mobile applications we don't
invest in gaming
why because we really don't have enough
the abilities to support these companies
to help them
to bring value to them okay in these
companies i mentioned
with the team that we have here six
investors well together
everybody understands technology very
very well
established the company or companies
both the companies at least two of us me
and leo that
took companies to values of billions of
dollars
we know how difficult it is we know how
to do it
yeah so we can bring value to our
company that's part of this
statement of a valid creation and
and i i'm very happy that this is done
at this area
which is so difficult to understand to
invest in
as new technologies so many people many
fans might tell you
we do abcdefg and diptec as well
which you know makes me smile which is
okay go ahead
uh and and we spoke about strategy of
refund or companies and i
i told you this statement the best
strategy they started that everybody
understands
that you are the only one that can
perform and and we do have the strategy
of
deep tech and we are the right people to
perform it
so grow ventures deep technology there
is a system and you started telling me
about all these different case studies
of how you're bringing in the
entrepreneurs sometimes you're pivoting
the entire strategy of a company by
bringing the venture partners and you're
mentioning that the most crucial piece
of it
is that you yourself embody deep
technology
as a person before the fun and when you
take
the combination or the group of people
that are driven by new technology and
you put them together
then you can create a lot of value as a
fund that specializes in this
why did we spend an hour before starting
this when you were telling me about
you know about silicon chips and the new
the new sensors for cameras that can see
through things why
why do why did we talk things dust
fog rain snow whatever it is yeah
why that's what i want to know because
that's exciting because hey
we are really creating the future we are
creating we are bringing products that
would
save lives people and there's nothing
that
makes you more excited than knowing
that you are doing something that would
impact the world
yeah of course it's nice to make money
but you know making money
after some time you will find that you
are a bit
um
you are content yeah you actually don't
care so much yeah okay we'll make
more money less money that's not the the
most important issue you need money to
survive you need money to live well
now for me uh making becoming more with
your doubling tripling
it's really it's meaningless at that
point yeah meaningless
maybe maybe they were the right word
here but if you make things which
are saving people's life and you make
this world a bit better
that's amazing i tell you story about my
this usb flash drive you know don't
usually flash live
well you know when you are in the doing
you don't really and
sometimes you don't really understand
what you do we did usb flash
clearly many many issues and problems
and standards and files and
patents and um as you know i'm the
inventor of the usb
flash drive so uh you know one memory
that i have office
great feeling ahead about the less than
a year after we bought the product to
the market
i went on a flight and it was just the
beginning of this product
uh people were using it but it didn't
jump from zero to
billion dollar in in a few months
so this was one of the first users that
actually used it he paid for it 50 bucks
by the way that was the initial price of
48 megabytes yeah
so i'm going on a plan and then someone
like someone
i was flying coach someone was walking
you know
against others to just to to say hello
to me and he said you don't know me
but your invention changed my life
said how could he change your life he
said the place i work in
is a place where i couldn't take my
computer or any data out of the
place so what i used to do which
probably was illegal
i used i bought this usb flash drive i
plugged it into the computer
i could take it with me go home earlier
because hey i know i'm going to complete
my job at home and then i could come
home and still see my kids you know
playing and be with them
after they went to sleep i plugged it
into my computer at home i finished what
i had to do i
waited went up the next day i came plug
it in
no one understood that i how fast i am
yeah but that's
and he said hey without your invention
you know i won't do it
so you change my life and getting to
hear from somebody
that your invention his life is wow
right uh i i later on you know i do
believe that with what we have done
i changed the life of many people at m
systems and later on even at modu
which was amazing company clearly a
tower which i
was a chairman and bought from a
catastrophe to
a company that has a value of several
billions of dollars today
and then other companies and other
activities that i had
um but but so you know it's great when
you establish a company
now i'm today the process that instead
of establishing one company which
you should establish one company all the
time means elements can do
two or three companies i'm not so
talented the same probably
but the ability that i can do it now is
20 companies
by investing being involved uh being a
chairman and active chairman
you said you're a chairman i believe in
17 or 18. no no i'm not german
we have about 20 companies at our
portfolio uh
about one third uh my company in my
company's i'm german almost of any
company
but i'm involved in other companies as
well uh
but what i mean i talk about involvement
it's not hey i'm the chairman i'm coming
once a month to a meeting and get the
honor hey mr chairman
nah i say i'm really down to earth i fly
with them to meetings i
i sit with them i i initiate for them a
business contacts
i i work with them in proposed right
proposals i
i help them to raise money i do we do
here at the front
uh critical design reviews with our
people their people
to talk about the systems we talk about
strategy
or help them change strategy so we are
very active as a fund
in the life of the companies and yeah
then finally
you know that success was done you know
you can
be happy when you buy a lotto lottery
ticket
and win but probably you'll be happy for
two days maybe two weeks okay
knowing that you were involved in doing
something that practical practically
changed life of many many people them
not just the employees but
users of this product that's something
that you will take for you
every day of your life and that's why
so that's something that i definitely
wish for myself eventually in my life
because i can't think of something about
more
that brings more contentness but i also
want to mention that you're talking
about the involvement and
all these different things that you
provide as a fund but i think that
we were missing the most inspiring
aspect for me
which is that the hour that we spent
wasn't and i refer to that because for
me it's the embodiment
of the type of investor that you
probably are and i hopefully one day we
get to work together but i see
somebody that beyond the interest in the
business and the people and
the impact you're interested in the
science you're interested in
why it works you need to convince
yourself
this is why it works and it's so
freaking cool and
because i understand how it works i can
i don't have to prove it to anybody else
because i know it will work
right so maybe i'll tell you something
about myself which it might be this
might sound funny
when i established my first one i i
talked with
you i tried to raise money i spoke with
a guy
that a very wealthy american guy
that came to israel and i met him here
and he was
quite quite happy with he was very happy
with what i told him and
and i do remember the self meeting we
had
he said i came to meet you and the first
thing he told me and it was joke
he said no i i speak with you i spoke
with you
and i can define exactly what are you
saying okay
go ahead he said you're a mentor
no one before in my life told me that
i'm a mentor but you know later on i
i did see myself really as somebody that
practically i was a mentor of many many
people which i'm very proud of
i know some of them you know some of
them
and and it's a great feeling to feel
that you
really change in this way life of people
as well
uh so yes i am trying to uh
i enjoy uh being being there as a
teacher so when
you when you come and we spoke about
which are making a swear
camera it's real short wave infrared
okay
uh and what's so unique about it and why
what's
done in order for that to work yeah that
makes me
very excited because i can see it
because really it's amazing
you know it's it's amazing it's i tell
you a short story about them
uh so when i when i went to do this
investment
you know they came with i do i'm
electrical engineer of course so i do
understand
and i did many many things in my life uh
so
i i did understand that technology
really seems to me very weird what they
want to do
and the the one of the first things i've
done i wrote to one of the
entrepreneurs is a guy that is a
professor at the hebrew university
so who do i know at hebrew university
i'm not joshua great guy smart guy
i i dealt with them uh uh i helped them
when they were very young company ziva
viral until now claimed that i was their
mentor
and he even says that i saved the
company because of some
consultation i gave to to them
this is a very funny story he tells to
other people that
they say without it dove there was not
no there was no mobile but he's
exaggerating anyway
but anyway i know i'm not so
you know do you know professor will
every do you know what that's weird what
they are doing is where
he kept his amazing answer he said uh he
said of course
he says same cause we are the same
corridor and he's a great guy
and about this really if it works if it
works it's a
it's a revolution it's a it's changing
the market rules
okay but then he added a very very short
sentence
the sentence which i never forget was
don't please pay attention the size of
this if is very very large
which means i'm not sure whether it's
going to work
and we took a we of course we went
deeply into
the the research and what was done and
how it was done
and what can be done and by the way my
relations with tower semiconductor was
very good because i could really walk
with the fact see that the fab is ready
to do process changes required
to to do this uh product which they
agreed
and that's really very very unique but
again it's my relationship with tower
they tell out i was jam after
so this actually
uh this works and and
the if doesn't exist anymore hey
of course it is exciting what will how
can it be
not if it won't be exciting probably i
won't be here i would do something else
you mentioned to me that you work an
average of 16 hours a day
i'm 14. i need to eat sometimes yeah old
sleep
you don't have to work a day i don't
have to walk at all for
making money but first you love it it's
part of
a you know i paid very very nice for
that uh that's clearly
i would do the job and hey if one of my
our lp's is seeing it i know it's a
dangerous statement but i would do the
job without playing without getting paid
i i i just enjoy very much what i'm
doing
and there's so much to be done that it
directs you
into the doing and
so there are people who likes other
stuff
i don't know i miss i i maybe i don't
watch tv
i don't want to read i do read books but
i read in saturdays only
uh you know i don't go to dinners i hate
dinners
i do sometimes go with the visitors
aboard but you know it's not for it's
part of the job
i um you know so
the the basic thing that i i can do is
do that yeah an engineer it's yeah it's
it's engineering it's business it's a
understanding technology is learning
well we need investment in a company
from weichmann institute
that deals with a chemical process
called uh that enabled actually
is new separation of chiralic material i
know you don't understand anything
don't worry it's okay 99.99
of the population means i know people
that know chemistry they didn't remember
what is it but it's a very very
important process for the
pharma industry actually and they came
to us and
and i found myself sitting at night and
i i'm talking about sitting
i just go to i won't go to sleep at 2
o'clock by the way i spent the evenings
by
reading this stuff so um
i find myself at night uh sitting
reading about keralic separation
how it's done what is it why it's
important what's the complexities
what's the implications when it's not
done they were
crazy by the way uh hey it's fascinating
i
i enjoy learning understanding
knowing stuff and uh and i'm still
i'm still learning at my age that's
something which i'm very very proud of
i'm still i'm a learner
yeah okay though it's uh i wish it was a
an hour not 20 minutes but i have a few
fun questions if you're ready
what was your favorite subject in high
school or middle school
or
i do have a memory for my my
kindergarten
where i stand in front of the teacher
holding my mother's hand
and they keep the nursery the
gun in it uh can i say kindergartner
kindergartner here
says uh i'm very sorry but he's not
mature enough to go to school and i feel
that my mother's
and i i'm angry with myself because i
was a chauvav i was uh
fully gone yeah i i i remember what i
thought when she said it
the day before every day end of the day
you had to take the chair and put
and put them on the table okay so i took
the
chair and put it on the table yeah you
know on as it is
and then the kindergartner was very
angry with me
so when she said to my mother i said wow
why do you
did so this too crazy what i might want
to tell you
and that goes off you know after that in
my school and then
first of all i did things out of the box
and i i was
late bloomer i was always every time
everywhere every time i went to do
something
it's like i stood if there is a if it's
running
yeah like everybody's standing there
ready to run okay
and then i'm standing there 10 meter
behind and hey they begin the guy
shoots everybody begins to run i begin
to run slowly you know some
but somehow people are breaking out
people um
and i i continue and i finally i get to
the front yeah
you realize it's it's a little bit of a
longer race than what most people think
and so it's a it's it's i'm a learner i
i do
i'm not the smartest guy in the world
i'm not clearly
my i'm full of deficiencies but i
all the time try to improve i work very
very hard on myself
constantly to improve uh what i like in
i
always was very good in mathematics i
just was saying
yeah that's right and who's one of your
role models
oh clearly my grandfather my grandfather
was enterpreneur
uh you know like a hundred hundred years
ago
and in poland the his here actually he's
both of his parents died when he was six
years ago he was adopted
uh but again he began very very low he
how do you say hello
workshop workshop he was working at the
workshop you know these machines that
are rolling and
and he learned the job and then he went
back to
his hometown and he built such a factory
and then they have some such a workshop
in there
and then he built effect he took he went
to italy bought
engineers and he bought he built the
first factory in
poland for doing silver silver you know
for food
knife faults which everybody was talking
about and then he
i bought he went to england and bought
equipment to do to
do a a oil digging and he opened a bank
and a lot of lot of stuff because he was
a real entrepreneur
and by the way that's important because
of the fact that he was entrepreneur
and he wasn't the set of mind of
entrepreneurs
his life was saved because entrepreneurs
are the people
that when they see a problem they face
the problem
they say okay we need to do a pivot
we'll do it people
doesn't work out we have to go to the
right we go to the right we go to life
whatever
we need to survive entrepreneurship
is a journey of survival yeah clearly
there are a lot of things
behind but survival is very important
all
right of entrepreneurship
you know just by talking with you it
came to my mind but in general i i lived
in my with my grandfather in the same
room we weren't in a rich family he came
to israel he didn't care about money
part of it i took as well to myself
today it's not that i care about my lp's
money yeah
i care about my partners it's not that i
want to maximize my money it's
absolutely not motorize me
but my grandfather i lived with him
actually at the same room
he lived with our home at our house and
we lived at the same room until he died
he died
exactly one week before
i was drafted so a friday
noon no one was at home except me and my
sister he died
in advance heart attack yeah uh
you know in jewish you sit shiva seven
days
this was saturday sunday friday
we finished the shiva seven days and
then sunday morning i was laughed
you know it took me years to understand
that he died exactly at the point
where he felt that he's not in it
anymore
and that's that's amazing and by the way
when it happened i didn't think about
this
exactly timing that he had
but this is reality so he was clearly
in a way my mentor i do have many
moments where
i do remember in the summers he would
take me to
jobs that he was creating for me
actually some of them was
very difficult i do remember myself
standing trying to
take out a tree
[Music]
yeah this this stuff this these days it
was you know built from wood it was all
plastic which
it was heavy and you know and i stand
there
and he didn't go here i went there to
take
take it out because we want to transfer
to the neighbors and
and it's very different he sees very
difficult for me say don't break up
stay yeah until now i have this walk
what's you know making my head
it's inspiring thank you for sharing it
that's uh i i love it
i don't have words there to describe
what i'm about i'm very thankful that he
showed it
and uh i'm very excited now to hear
about three words that you would choose
to describe yourself yeah i have hints
to what they are about
but how would you you have to look at it
as a spectator
who's dope well but that's i think the
first thing is
is that i'm a learner i'm improving i'm
working on constantly
improve myself whatever i'm doing i
always learn and i always try to be
better than what i was before
so that's the first thing the second
thing
i determined that's that's part of it
the third thing i i surprised you uh i
think that i'm
a very much
a operations research oriented
i was a teacher i somehow when i was at
the
fifth class at elementary school i was
sick my father bought
home a book about operations research
don't ask me why i think that he bought
it because
there was uh the week where they can can
buy
chips it looks very very cheap this was
super cheap probably no one was buying
it so he bought it
and i was sick at home and so he he took
it to me
and then and i was sick so i was at home
and i
i but by the way it's very well i i
never i really
really sick in my life but i was reading
it because and you know since it was the
only thing
only book he bought me that i already
spoke and it was
written very very well and it gave me
great understanding
of combinatorics and statistics and
and it somehow influenced my mind so i
was very very good in
in anything that relates to that and
then i became a teacher i was a teacher
uh at the the tel aviv university i was
teaching a couple of years
operations research i began as a stager
somebody who helps the professor
and he went to colombia and i became the
teacher
while i didn't have any second degree
event it's a funny story by itself
but i was teaching operations research
and and i think that it
gives me a lot because practically every
each one of us is taking
all need to take many decisions in his
life
if your co you need to take lots of
decisions if you are a venture capital
fund manager
your life is decision taking yeah if you
are chairman of company
as well uh any question how do you take
decisions and
i think that i am a good decision taker
i love it
when you mention also before the show
maybe it was even during the show
everything is
a big balagan but you mentioned that
it's you know
making a decision that's the most
crucial piece of it
learning from that decision of course
accepting that the decision may be the
wrong one yes
but making that decision and being a
person that
you perhaps as an investor can count on
to keep making these decisions
promptly intellectually but also take
ownership over them and then
pivot the next time because there will
always be a next time it's a
never-ending journey
and and then you will always choose
somebody to make that decision but you
can trust will make that decision
decision taking is difficult because you
know it seems like you know it's a
you have to write five items and say
this is it's
so much more so much more complicated
because when you deal with people
sometimes maybe you get to see a ceo
that is making a mistake would you tell
him it's a mistake
would you say hey it's a mistake do it
and then like oh you let him do his
mistakes and learn or maybe
stopping before it really gets into
doing a very bad mistake
nothing is simple nothing is really
simple
uh and by the way i do claim you know
the the the guts feeling yeah
now you should say hey oh you operate
there are no gods feeling you have to
take these things very very logically no
no no guts feeling actually a collection
of many many
small decisions on many many items this
guy was looking at you when he came into
the room
that you gather into a
actually a set of a good of a decision
it's not really god's feeling it's
practical it's analyzing many many
factors into that
so yeah it is important uh to understand
how to take decisions
it is important on the other side how to
lead people
by letting them take decisions this is
more important even
though thank you very much my pleasure
this was wonderful
i needed to increase the the show length
for the first
for our next episode and i'm already
saying that we're going to do another
episode because i i just i i'm
leaving with many more questions that i
came in with but thank you very much